MODERATOR: Thank you
guys for joining us here
at the second day of I/O at
the YouTube Distribute Space.
And basically, we want to
get at one question here.
Once you build a great product,
how do you get it out there?
We've talked so much about
design and development
in other I/O sessions.
And that's what we
really want to get at,
is once you've done those two
things, how do you distribute?
I couldn't be more excited to be
joined by Victoria Ransom, who
is the co-founder of
Wildfire and this talk
is aptly called "How to Spread
Your Product like Wildfire."
We're big fan of puns here on
the YouTube team and at Google.
So Victoria, before we dive into
details, why don't you tell us
a little bit about what Wildfire
is and how it got started.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Sure.
So Wildfire is a social
media marketing SAAS company.
So basically, we have a suite
of tools that help companies
with different aspects of
their social media marketing.
So whether it's being able to
track what people are saying
about a brand and
respond to them,
or track analytics to see
how they're performing
across different
social networks,
creating engaging campaigns.
It sort of like a one-stop shop
for your social media marketing
needs.
We started a company in
2008 actually because we
had our problem and we
were trying to solve it.
So we had a travel
business at the time.
We created a Facebook brand
page for that business.
Immediately experienced
what I think
a lot of brands
experience, which is OK,
I created my fan page, now what?
I have no fans.
They're not engaging.
How do I spread the word?
We wanted to give away
a free trip as a way
to drive engagement.
Had to built a Facebook
application to do that.
We felt like that
was going to be
a barrier, the entry for a
lot of small and medium sized,
and it turn out, large
businesses as well.
So rather than build
something just for ourselves,
we build a really simple,
initially simple--
it grew over time-- application
for running these kinds
of engaging campaigns
on Facebook,
initially and then we spread
to Google+ and YouTube
and Pinterest and others.
So yeah.
That was the initial idea.
It grew like wildfire.
So I've heard that pun before.
And I guess when we got
acquired by Google in 2012
we were 400 employees, had
about 30,000 customers,
and had grown a pretty
successful business.
So we hit on a good idea.
MODERATOR: That's right.
And I want to-- I saw this
video when they announced
the Wildfire acquisition
to their entire team.
And you almost announced it
as a surprise in this video.
VICTORIA RANSOM: It was
a total surprise, yeah.
MODERATOR: And it almost
seemed like an episode
of Oprah's "Favorite Things."
It was like everyone was
getting a gift and going crazy.
And just-- it was one of
the most passionate videos
I've seen.
So your team must have
been super excited
about the acquisition.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Yeah,
the team was great.
We had a great team and
a great team culture
and then combining
that with people
being excited about
joining Google.
MODERATOR: Of course.
VICTORIA RANSOM: It was
a lot of excitement.
MODERATOR: So let's
rewind a bit because I
think for a lot of I/O attendees
that maybe are developing
their own apps or starting
their own businesses, that's
the dream, to one
day be in a position
to successfully exit or be able
to grow such a big business.
So who were some of your
first clients that you--
You said you identified
the pain point
and how did you
bring on the clients
to develop the Wildfire platform
and get your product out there?
VICTORIA RANSOM: Yeah.
I mean I think initially,
we did whatever
we could bring the
first clients in.
So getting those first
reference client,
typically if you're a B2B
business like we were,
is everything.
So the first clients were
companies we got Kayak,
we got Zappos.
How did we get them?
Zappos, I knew a friend
of a friend of a friend.
I dug until I could
get in the company.
MODERATOR: And what
would you tell them?
Would you reach out with emails?
Or how would you?
VICTORIA RANSOM: Well,
you know what actually
did that was quite
effective back then is--
and as my co-founder over here,
he set a lot of these pages up.
We would actually,
at that stage,
it was so early with brand
pages, a lot of brands
haven't even claimed their
brand pages on Facebook.
So we'd go in and create a
brand page for a company.
And then we'd put a Wildfire
campaign on the brand page
because our product was so
easy, it took us five minutes
to create a campaign.
And then we'd write
to them and say, "Hey,
do you want to claim this Page?
And while you're at it,
you should use Wildfire."
So that was good hook.
I mean, it was
very early on lead.
But basically, we
used our network.
The product was free
for those first clients.
And then a little
bit later, when
we got a little
bit more traction,
we were able to
attract bigger brands.
So actually Facebook was
one of our first clients.
And we did a campaign
that we probably
should have charged tens of
thousands of dollars for.
We charged them I think $5,000.
It was a token amount.
We stayed-- I remember-- we
stayed up for pretty much
three nights in a
row getting it done.
Once you have that
reference like that,
then all the doors open.
So I think we were scrappy
with us first clients,
to get the references.
And then later, we employed
a lot of marketing techniques
to really scale that.
But those were
the first clients.
MODERATOR: That's awesome.
So you hit on something that
I think is so important.
You didn't wait.
You didn't stop and
think, OK, maybe
we should create a presentation,
talk about our product,
and get it out there.
You literally created
a page for the brand
and put your product on it and
give them the proof of concept
right there.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Totally
and in fact, added to that,
is we created a prototype.
And that's what we
got out to market.
And that took two
and a half months
or something, or two months.
That was not the product that
we then went to market with.
But with that, we're able
to validate the market,
get some client on
board, and then we
could say, "Wow, this is
really worth investing in."
Then the main product that
ended up really scaling
took a year and a half to build.
But the more you can
prototype, get it out
to clients, the better.
And I would say, I think,
some entrepreneurs are really
afraid of getting their idea out
because someone might steal it.
Maybe that's what worth being
afraid of but I would say much
more often businesses fail
because you don't get out
there quick enough,
you don't get out
there aggressively enough
then because someone
comes in and steals your idea.
MODERATOR: Do you ever have
a moment where you thought
you were being too aggressive
with how you got out Wildfire.
They're like, "Oh man, if
we put out this campaign,
somebody else may see it
and they may take it up
or another big business can--"
VICTORIA RANSOM:
You know it never
ceases to amaze me how there's
so many times with the business
where we felt like
we were doomed.
So we're a big player.
There several times where
really big players, much bigger
than us, looked like they
were entering our space,
or they were entering a space.
And we were tiny.
We might have been four
people at the time.
And we felt like,
"Oh, it's all over."
And it never ceases
to amaze me how
slow, especially big
companies, big companies are
in moving into a market.
So I just wouldn't worry
about them that much.
I just get on and do your thing.
And then with startups,
there's generally
room for a few startups.
It's weird that
one startup's going
to come in and just
totally take over from you.
So I think competitors are
really great because they make
you move faster and they
scare you a little bit
and they motivate you.
They're not worth focusing that
much, though, I don't think.
MODERATOR: So in addition to
being aggressive, Victoria,
I think something that's
so smart about what
you and the Wildfire team
did is that you guys tried
to be industry leaders
for social marketing
by putting content out there
and developing white papers
and webinars there
were so popular.
Can you talk about
what exactly those were
and how they became so popular?
VICTORIA RANSOM: Yeah, I
think Wildfire actually
never-- we're a
very lean company.
We never raised a lot of money.
So marketing, we never did a
ton of big brand marketing.
We were not in magazines.
We were not all over airports.
Some of our competitors were
and it was quite successful
for them.
So we had to be a
lot more scrappy
and I think creative
with our marketing.
And what we really found
was very, very successful
was basically
building an expertise
in the market and
really great content
to help people be
more successful
with social marketing.
And we distributed via
very successful webinars.
So we got to the point where we
were having tens of thousands
of companies signing
up for webinars.
Our social channels
were all about content,
educational content.
We would do things like
have question hour,
we could write in to
our experts and would
respond with questions.
MODERATOR: That would be
you and Alan responding?
VICTORIA RANSOM: Uh, initially.
MODERATOR: Waiting for
the questions to come in.
VICTORIA RANSOM:
After a time, no.
We had a fabulous
social marketing,
Social Media Manager
called [? Maya ?]
who would do a lot of that.
And newsletters.
So all of those things are
were really successful for us.
Of course, you've also got
to have a big mailing list.
So we were able
to build that up.
But, yeah.
And I think that was great
for us for two reasons.
One, it was a really cost
effective form of marketing.
But the other thing
is, in our industry,
it was as much
about the perceived
expertise of the company
as it was the product,
whether someone was
on board or not.
So it turned out to be
really strong sales tool
because many times,
we would close deals
because we had a great
product and the client really
believed we knew how to help
them with social marketing.
So it was critical
for us, I'd say.
MODERATOR: Absolutely so talk
to talk to me about-- I want
to empathize with the
I/O attendee who is here,
the developers.
Maybe I need to focus
on my product 100%
and develop that,
as opposed to you
guys did so many things where
I wonder, like around the table
at Wildfire, do
you guys talk about
like "Oh, this newsletter
could be distracting
from our main focus,
this webinar."
This isn't what our
product is about.
Because I feel like when
you're so lean and so scrappy
like you said, it's so
hard to do so many things.
But you guys were able to.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Yeah, it is.
And I'd say that content
marketing came later
when we'd already got a
little bit of traction.
Actually in those
early days, what
really mattered most
was one, as I described,
was reaching out and
getting reference customers.
So sales, basically.
And it started with the two
of us being sales people.
And then we bought
sales people in.
But the other thing
is, our product--
our product itself was a great
lead gen tool for two reasons.
One, it was actually
a very viral product.
So any time a company published
a campaign via Wildfire--
so basically what the
initial product that Wildfire
has was a really
easy way for you
to run a giveaway or a
coupon or a photo contest.
So that would get
published and potentially
thousands or tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands
of consumers would then
engage with that campaign.
Well at the bottom
of every campaign,
it said "Powered by
Wildfire" with a link right
through to our product.
So that turned out to be
really viral way for us
to generate leads.
Then when you click
through to the product,
it was dead simple to sign
up for the product for free.
Many people did not go
any further than that.
But then we'd capture
their email address.
And we were getting,
initially, hundreds
and then thousands
of emails a day.
That's when it then became
valuable to re-market
to those people.
At the beginning,
we didn't have time
to do that, to do webinars.
So we just did it
in an automated way.
So basically, if
someone signed up,
three days after you
signed up, you've
got this friendly
email from Victoria
saying, "Hey, I
saw you signed up.
Here's some tips
for how to succeed."
And then seven
days later, it said
"I noticed you haven't
finished your account."
And the amazing thing is,
people would respond to that
and they say Victoria,
"I can't believed
you emailed me at 2 AM.
You're so dedicated."
MODERATOR: So kind of you.
VICTORIA RANSOM:
It's an auto email
but they didn't even realize.
So, that was how we
did it initially.
And then we really
had enough bandwidth
to do the content marketing.
MODERATOR: That's fantastic.
So it sounds like
it started with more
of an email newsletter and
became more of a webinar,
the white papers
came afterwards.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Yeah,
those were additives.
Yeah, the newsletters
were always important.
And this automated nurturing
was really important to us.
MODERATOR: I see.
And the other thing that you
talked about-- its sounds
like you embedded the
distribution of your product
within the development.
You put in the
"Powered by Wildfire"
to make sure that any
product went viral.
Was that a tension
point internally?
Did people talk about we want
to make the product as pure
to the brand of our
clients as possible
and keep Wildfire away from it?
Or did you guys,
was that a clear--
VICTORIA RANSOM:
Well, it actually
ended up becoming a really
nice differentiator for us
in our pricing tiers.
So what ended up happening
is for a large brands,
they actually cared
about branding.
So we took away the
"Powered by Wildfire"
and were able to charge
them 10 times more--
I'm not joking-- than the
smaller businesses who really
didn't care about having
the "Powered by Wildfire."
So the smaller businesses were
largely using the same product.
We didn't make as
much money from them
but they help us this market it.
And the large brands
would get what
was called our
"white label product"
and there's no
"Powered by Wildfire."
So it was actually a
really nice pricing--
MODERATOR: Sounds like
a total a win-win.
That's fantastic.
So Victoria, you
talked a bit about how
to become content
leader in terms
of distributing your product.
What other advice would you have
for a developer entrepreneur
who's just trying to get
their product off the ground
and struggling a bit.
VICTORIA RANSOM: I've
tried different things.
I mean I wish I could say
there's one magic bullet.
In our case, we ended up finding
that content marketing was
really successful.
PR, by the way, was highly
successful for us as well.
MODERATOR: What did you guys do
for PR to push your product out
there and expand
the distribution?
VICTORIA RANSOM:
We were persistent.
So that was one thing.
You can't just send
one email to a blogger
and expect to suddenly take off.
Having said that, don't
piss off bloggers, either.
So that's important.
I think we were fairly creative.
So we tried to think about,
both with our content marketing
and with blogs, that instead of
just thinking about pushing out
some information about
product or our company,
we tried to think about what's
a different angle that we could
take that might be really
interesting to the readers
of that blog.
So I remember when Facebook
launched their Timeline,
we basically came
out with an app.
We did it, we built it
really, really quickly that
would make it really easy
for brands to switch over
to the new Timeline format.
And got that out to the blogs.
And basically said
this is free for the x
first 1,000 people to
sign up or something.
That was a win for
the bloggers' readers
so then they got it out there.
So instead of being a
promotion pitch for Wildfire,
it was something that
was great and useful
for the bloggers' audience.
Therefore, they're
willing to get it out.
So I think thinking
a little bit out
of the box of like
"I don't want to just
want promote my company."
How can I in a roundabout way
promote the company and it'll
address the needs of the
bloggers' audience as well.
MODERATOR: Of course.
Yeah, it seems with so many
of your distribution moves,
you're trying to offer
more value than you take.
And in some ways, I
bet a lot of consumers
got value out of
what you put out
there between the white
papers, the webinars,
the early sign-ups without even
signing up for the product.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Right.
Oh yeah.
Tons of them were
getting a lot of value
and never became our customers.
But I think you're
absolutely right.
It's so much easier
to get someone to tune
in if you're talking about
"to 10 tips to distribute
via Facebook" than "look
at my product features."
But enough of them
converted, though.
It was very
worthwhile doing that.
MODERATOR: And I think that's
such an important insight
because so many times,
nowadays, people just
try to push the product in
your face and get it out there.
I think the roundabout
way that you
went about promoting
Wildfire was so smart.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Yeah, I think
it's much more successful,
otherwise people are being
bombarded all the time
with the new product.
MODERATOR: Before we open
it up to you guys as Q&A
with Victoria, I wanted to ask.
What's something that you
look back at your time
in starting Wildfire,
your journey
up to the acquisition
by Google, what
would you've done differently?
What mistakes did you make?
What wold you've changed
about your journey?
So perhaps people in the
audience could avoid them.
VICTORIA RANSOM: Yeah.
I think probably some of the
mistakes we made, and they
maybe so relevant for
the stage that you're at,
so if I can think of an
earlier mistake, I'll add it.
Sort of around scaling that I
think we didn't always catch up
fast enough, in terms of
putting the right leadership
in the right structure
in the company.
It's great when you're
a really small company,
you want to be flat.
And it's all about flat and
we don't have any hierarchy.
We don't have any
structure and you
realize over time, that's
actually a mistake.
So I think that was
something that we
had some pain points
because of it.
Actually, I mentioned before
that we mostly focused on
content marketing,
social marketing,
didn't do a lot of
brand marketing.
As it turns out, building
your brand is important, too.
And we had a competitor
did that very well.
They had to raise a
lot of money to do it
but your perception
in the market
actually counts for a lot,
especially when it's time
to get acquired, for example.
So don't neglect just building
your brand perception.
There's a lot of
companies out there
that are riding a heck of a wave
on the perception out their,
of the size of their
company that's not even true
but it pays off.
So I think we could have
done more around branding,
getting the word out there
about how well we were doing.
MODERATOR: So with that, I
want to open it up to you guys.
If you have questions, ask
Victoria about the Wildfire
journey and how she got started.
AUDIENCE: Hi, is there anything
that you would do differently
if you were starting today?
VICTORIA RANSOM: Let's see.
What would I do differently
if I started over today?
You know, so I'm-- my co-founder
and I are not developers
ourselves.
So I think we got the
product up and running
in a very scrappy way.
We hired a couple of
developers in Estonia
and we built this great product.
We would have done
better to bring
more senior technical leader
into the company early on.
I think it was a great way to
get the product off the ground
and validated in a really
scrappy way, that's
really good.
But once it started
taking off then
we found there was a hell a
lot of a lot we had rebuild
and the whole foundation
needed to be redone.
So looking back,
I think we could
have bought in--
we initially found
a really fantastic
technical leader, CTO,
but we probably should have
bought that person in early.
Having said that, it's a bit
of a chicken and an egg, right?
Because you create this
beautiful foundation
that's going to
scale beautifully
and if the product
doesn't take off.
So I'm not sure that
it is such a bad thing
but we got some pain points
because of that decision,
I think.
So one thing I'd
probably do differently.
AUDIENCE: Actually, you
answered my question.
But in a more general
way, what is the winning
teams that you
see for a startup?
What's the combination of the
talents that needs to be there?
VICTORIA RANSOM:
A great question.
So first of all, I'd say when
you're picking your team,
especially co-founders,
first of all,
just make sure that you have
very complimentary skills
and not overlapping skills.
I think so often, people
become co-founders
because they met at work.
They met at business school.
They met wherever.
And they'd quite often end
up having quite similar skill
sets.
And I think, not
only is that a waste,
it's a recipe for disaster.
Because you end up stepping
on each other's toes
and power struggles can ensue.
So I would say, clearly if it's
some kind of technical product,
then you need a
technical leader.
Maybe not right away
because we didn't.
We are able to test
out market first.
But pretty soon, you do.
And then, and this is where
I think a lot of startups
make mistakes as
well, you need someone
who's just going to be
really aggressive on the go
to market side.
So many fabulous
products never make
it get off the ground
because nobody really
thought about how
to get them there.
So in our case,
in the B2B space,
someone they can really build
out a sales organization
is absolutely critical.
If it's not B2B,
then someone who's
a real genius with
marketing, content
marketing, viral marketing
absolutely critical.
And then, you need
someone who can really
express the vision
of the company,
motivate people, get
investors excited.
Someone in the company
needs to basically
be a salesperson but not a
salesperson going to clients,
a salesperson for the company.
And don't take the negative
connotation of that.
I mean getting the vision out
there, getting people excited.
Because that's a huge part--
it's basically taking an idea
and getting people
to give you money,
getting people to work for
you for many hours a day,
often, for not as much as they
could make somewhere else.
So someone's going to
have to be a rallying
point for the company.
Now I just listed about
five different things.
You can find that in two people.
You can find that
in three people
but you've got to have all
of those components I think.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Victoria.
Thanks so much for coming.
Just two questions.
So I was wondering if you
elaborate a little bit
on the Google acquisition.
So did they approach you?
Did you approach them?
VICTORIA RANSOM: Great question.
They approached us.
So-- and that's ideal.
I mean, if you can
get to the point
where actually the
acquirers coming to you,
that's a really good thing.
In our case, what happened is
a couple of other companies
were interested in
acquiring Wildfire.
I think Google got wind of that.
There was consolidation
happening in our industry
and Google reached out and it
all happened very, very quickly
actually.
But for everyone who
is an entrepreneur,
I would say you ideally don't
want to be in a position
where you're going to
an acquirer saying,
"I want to sell my company."
But it's really
important to make
sure the acquirers
know who you are.
So something, talking
about other things
we could have done
differently, we probably
should've done more of
is building relationships
with the Googles, the
Salesforces, the Oracles,
the IBMs of the world.
You do it under the
guise of a partnership.
So you reach out
and there's always
a way to potentially
partner with these companies
just so they know who you are.
Then you're on
their radar and then
hopefully, when they're to
acquire, they'll reach out.
So that's actually
been quite [INAUDIBLE]
that is quite
important, I think.
AUDIENCE: And then
my other question
is, can you elaborate
on your experience?
So you said that you didn't
have technical experience
but I'm assuming you have
a marketing background
or something in that field.
VICTORIA RANSOM: You'd think so.
But what my experiences is,
I grew up in New Zealand,
came over to the US for college.
I did two years in the finance
industry, which was useful
because it exposed me
to lots of entrepreneurs
and I learned how to
build financial models.
I guess that was useful.
Was not passionate about that.
Started-- Alan and I
started our first company
in the travel industry.
So we did learn a lot
from that business.
It was an online business
about marketing, SEO content
marketing, building
a great website.
So I guess, not a
marketer by trade
but learned a lot
through that business.
And I then did go
to business school
and then started Wildfire.
But truthfully, there's
nothing about my background
that said I should have started
a social media marketing
software company.
And I think that's kind of the
nature of entrepreneurship.
Truly, it is so much about
common sense, intuition,
creativity, and not at all about
what you read in a textbook
or learn in a classroom.
And what you don't know, you
can read online or ask someone.
So, I don't think anyone--
there's no background that's
ideal for an
entrepreneur, I think.
MODERATOR: So with
that, I just want
to say thank you to Victoria
for joining us and--
VICTORIA RANSOM: That was fun.
Thank you.
MODERATOR: Thank
you for joining us.
Appreciate it.